[Musique]
quel monde on vit
si quelquefois notre imagination
débordante nous emporte dans l'ouest
américain avec ces éoliennes perdu dans
des espaces immense et désertique en
france la réalité est tout autre
ces éoliennes comme des fantômes de fer
témoins d'un temps industrielles passées
sont bien présentes dans notre quotidien
particulièrement dans le centre ouest de
la france
on les appelle les éoliennes boulet
[Musique]
cette incroyable histoire industrielle
est aujourd'hui la passion d'un homme
hors du temps jean-claude pestel sauveur
du relief
[Musique]
nous sommes à aire-sur-adour l'éolienne
est l'une des rallyes soit restaurer et
qui fonctionne au de 24 mètres elle est
aujourd'hui une référence
construite à la fin du 19ème pour
alimenter en eau le château du vilaine
sa restauration s'est terminée en 2005
les éoliennes monnaie des canifs mans
c'est une idée de génie
[Musique]
dont l'ondé journal
le secteur le retard et le papillon
l'orientation sont les trois éléments
fondamentaux de les aliens donc le but
du stator s'est dirigé vers vers leurs
corps pour qu'ils aient le plus de force
possible
l'utilité du papillon l'orientation
c'est d'orienter en permanence et le
lire ou les éoliennes au vent
dès qu'elle va tourner et va orienter
l'ensemble de l'éolienne directement au
vent avec le papillon de l'orientation
le lien se trouve en permanence
[Musique]
à l'intérieur de l'éolienne dans le fût
il ya un axe qui traverse jusqu'en bas
bon ces taxes et entraînez en rotation
par le pignon en haut c'est à dire que
vous avez un couple c'est à dire deux
pignons inquiets sur le retard et acquis
et sur la ce qui est sûr la barre qui va
jusqu'en bord pour transmettre mouvement
de rotation pompe
en espérant que vous avez tout compris
et l'eau arrivait ainsi dans un
réservoir pour alimenter le château et
ses jardins
[Musique]
ma chanson
cette éolienne des reçus rendre est
l'une des fiertés de jean-claude pestel
cette incroyable passionnés consacre sa
vie et cette invention il connaît toutes
les éoliennes de france et d'ailleurs
passage dans le bureau secret de cette
historienne de la baule et cartes
postales des simples en tout est
minutieusement référencés c'est un
gardien du vent j'ai travaillé 43 ans
dans l'aéronautique
et lorsque vous regardez une éolienne
beau les deux faces nous nous en avions
une sève qui était en train de rouiller
et ça ressemble à l'entrée l'air d'un
réacteur moderne et bien je dis pourquoi
pas ne pas s'occuper d'une éolienne
j'ai appris son fonctionnement sont
historiques je fait l'inventaire de ces
machines là en touraine en france et
quelques jeunes à l'étranger
l'ancien mécanicien naviguant sur 747
jean-claude piste elle éditera un
ouvrage sur les éoliennes ball et le
berre il y à 70,6 en touraine vous avez
remarqué
nous venons de dire éolien bollée
loubert et pourquoi je suis obligée
d'employer le mot ball et le berre
puisque c'est quand même monsieur mollet
qui a déposé
1 un brevet j'avais un truc je pouvais
en 1868 et il a repris derrière son fils
a repris derrière cette division
éolienne est au bout de certes d'un
certain nombre d'années d'exploitation
il a vendu son affaire d'éoliennes en
1896 odyssey un certain monsieur lauber
est le monsieur le maire a continué à
construire des éoliennes mollet mais les
allait il les a appelés mollet le berre
mon frigidaire mais qui étaient les
boulons une famine ans celle qui compte
à plusieurs générations d'inventeurs qui
assimileront vite qu'il fallait
industrialisés leur gigue
c'est ici que tout a commencé dans cette
maison au centquatre de l'avenue bollée
au départ il ya jean baptiste officier
de santé puis jean-baptiste amédée qui
créera les fonds des deux cloches à
orléans au mans ernest sylvain boulay
sera lui aussi fondeurs de cloches et
concepteur des éoliennes il aura trois
fils et volées clocher automobile ernest
julbo les baies l'hydraulique et angus
de bol et qui reprendra le secteur des
éoliennes
une autre génération poursuivra
l'aventuré les volets ouvriront même la
première usine en france d'automobiles
ils testeront aussi sur le circuit de
l'époque et inventeront le fameux
tricycle appelé le tube elmer il ouvrait
le soir son parc
il y avait mon frangin dos des flambeaux
et le savoir romney y promener les gens
dans son parc en voiture à vapeur
ils se sont fâchés les deux frères se
sont fâchés parce que l'un disait que
c'étaient des lanternes vénitiennes et
leur disait que c'étaient les lampions
images d'un autre temps celle de la
première éolienne dans le cadre feutré
silencieux les archives départementales
de la sarthe
nous retrouvons que gérard bollée 90 ans
qui a passé union partie de sa vie à
faire l'inventaire de l'épopée de son
illustre famille
l'oeil pétillant un humour al anglaise
et ce rien de nostalgie d'une époque
formidable
on est parti de la fin du xviiie siècle
la première république a eu beau dire
que l'on pouvait guillotiné lavoisier
parce que la république n'est pas besoin
de savants n'empêche que la science
bouillet au moins autant que la
philosophie et on était encore à leur
époque une émulation et en même temps
une difficulté de faire comprendre aux
générations anciennes tout ce qu'il y
avait de nouveau en mathématiques en
moyenne traiter les problèmes mais on
découvrait que l'hydraulique la façon
dont les eaux se comporte
sous la pression quand ya pas de presse
sur les tourbillons on découvrait tout
ça il y avait un merveilleux de
bouillonnement mais c'est un peu que
maintenant avec ce qu'on appelle le
digital de numérique
il ya un bouillonnement terrible que des
générations apprennent à maîtriser mais
ne comprennent pas forcément
[Musique]
voyage au pays des éoliennes
la touraine en compte le plus grand
nombre
et pourquoi donc la raison est simple la
loire et ses châteaux et ses nombreuses
résidences d'été propriété
d'aristocrates ou de riches industriels
venus de la région parisienne mais pas
seulement elle était aussi dans le
domaine public comme ici à dos lui le
sec la bien nommée qui faute de cours
d'eau est bien la commune fit construire
un puits une éolienne pour alimenter de
l'avoir mais aussi d'en faire un point
d'eau utile à tous ce fut le cas aussi
pour la plus connue de la région
dell est multicolore que vous ne pouvez
pas louper au bord de la nationale 10 à
sorigny une fierté pour la commune et
marques de l'histoire pour les habitants
ne saurait ni le fait d'avoir retrouvé
surtout les plus anciens qui ont connu
l'éolienne à provisions lavoir municipal
pour laisser ses taux si ça a été un
grand moment de voir leurs éoliennes
réimplanter puisque c'est le même modèle
qu'il y avait autrefois et on a même si
vous voulez dans le bureau de
l'association
un monsieur qui habitait quand il était
petit au pied des éoliennes il avait la
maison qui jouxte l éolienne donc pour
lui vous pensez c'est très émouvant de
retrouver ce qu'il a connu quand il
avait 56 ans étant certes ce n'est pas
celle d'origine
elle vient du loir et cher mais peu
importe
retrouvons notre sauveur d'éoliennes
police et à l'école d'amboise celle ci a
une particularité et à plusieurs titres
et voilà la seule éoliennes classées de
la touraine celle du château de la
gabinière construite en 1888
c'était aux lianes a subi beaucoup de
dégâts notamment pendant la dernière
guerre mondiale puisque les troupes
allemandes qui se trouvait l'autre côté
de la loire pilonné ce coin
d'observation et il y avait certainement
des gens qui observaient ses troupes et
qui étaient installés en haut de cette
éolienne
ce qui explique qu'on trouve encore des
impacts de gros calibre dans cette
éolienne
infatigable enquêteurs nous voici
maintenant à la firme modèle du 19e de
marolles qui fut inauguré en grande
pompe en 1877 dans le président de la
république
le maréchal de magma particularité la
ferme possède deux éoliennes et d'unique
dans la région elles sont classées en
trois catégories
voici la plus grande
[Musique]
et c'est une numéro 3 qui fait 5 m de
diamètre
[Musique]
celle-ci pu et l'autre dans un puits
à l'intérieur de ce bâtiment un puits
qui fait 43 mètres de profondeur et
lorsque l'éolienne ne tournait pas c'est
à dire en absence de vent une machinerie
installé dans ce bâtiment une machine à
vapeur pouvait entraîner le système de
pompage deux sets de 7 éoliennes mais
également cette machine à vapeur
entraîné toute une ligne d'arbre pour
alimenter pour faire mouvoir les outils
nécessaires à cette ferme
il est vrai que la plupart des éoliennes
étaient des commandes de maisons
bourgeoises et châteaux et aujourd'hui
certains en sont les dignes héritiers de
cette incroyable mécanique comme au
château de mazères c'était éoliennes
serait la plus ancienne et daterait de
1876 en général les éoliennes étaient
installés pour apporter de l'eau aux
domaines alors ça servait souvent pour
remplir des bassins des châteaux d'eau
qui alimentait la maison et puis des
bassins qui pouvait servir à arroser les
jardins autour éventuellement même donné
de l'eau des animaux
des élevages donc si vous les savez en
gros 3 utilité ménagères plaisance et
agricoles dire que ce soit un très bel
objet non dire que c'est une très belle
technique
oui maintenant après chacun est libre
d'apprécier si c'est beau propos ça fait
partie du paysage
[Musique]
1890 la première éolienne dit
industriels permettant de générer de
l'électricité est mise au ban par le
danois poul la cour l'éolienne
américaine pour puiser de l'eau arrivera
elle dans les années 1920 et aujourd'hui
pour jean claud pestel ce patrimoine
industriel et et la mémoire du temps
fait rendre hommage aux concepteurs de
cette éolienne qui ont conçu cette
éolienne au 19e siècle et qui sont tout
de même remarquable les volets ont quand
même fait beaucoup de réalisations pas
que les éoliennes les bélier hydraulique
les cloches les voitures et bien
d'autres choses de la fin du xviiie au
début du xxème siècle dans cette période
on invente un tout ou presque
et si inventions seront à jamais des
bases de notre moderne
[Musique]